you don't know where to go until you
know where you're from this is why
history is so important most big
mistakes have been made in the past and
we do not want to make them again but
there are also many discoveries we wish
we had found sooner because they change
the world as we know it stay tuned if
you want to know more about the
discoveries that will keep changing our
lives in the future if this is your
first time visiting our channel don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up today we're
showing you ten amazing discoveries that
rewrote history the Rosetta Stone if you
ever try to read hieroglyphics this
mission seems almost impossible
researchers were also confused when they
first saw these symbols looking like
animals waves and characters the written
language had been dead for 2,000 years
so they couldn't find anyone to
translate it
that was until a French soldier found
the Rosetta Stone in 1799 during
Napoleon Bonaparte's Egyptian campaign
it contained passages written in three
different scripts Greek Egyptian
hieroglyphics and Egyptian demotic the
rosetta stone was commissioned by
Ptolemy v to claim that he was the
rightful Pharaoh of Egypt but for
archaeologists it meant so much more
they read that it was written in sacred
and native and Greek characters this is
how they understood that the same text
was written in three different scripts
french egyptologist jean-francois
Champollion finally cracked the code
after teaching himself ancient language
he found out the symbols were used to
represent objects sounds and groups of
sounds it was the key to understanding
the culture of those who lived thousands
of years ago without this discovery we
would not have known anything about this
ancient civilization without this we
would know barely anything about the
Egyptian mythology who thought that a
stone could rewrite history fingerprints
they have always been right under our
noses this whole time fingerprints are
part of what make us unique individuals
it was not until the 19th century that
we discovered that it was a great way to
identify criminals but did you know that
the ancient Babylonians discovered that
we all had different fingerprints
thousands of years before that they
pressed their fingers into clay to
record business transactions then
Chinese people used finger impressions
with ink on paper not only for business
but also to identify children then in
the 20th century law enforcement
officials started identifying criminals
with their finger prints but it wasn't
as easy as you might think at that time
there were no computers investigators
had to look at them one by one for days
and sometimes they didn't even find a
match it wasn't until the 1970s that the
system was automated with a computer and
there are now more and more ways to know
who we are with our footprints our lip
prints and our tongue prints this way to
identify individuals completely change
the way detectives investigate we know
the unique story of everyone from the
trace they leave on everything that they
touch and by having access to this
information we can make it so fewer
criminals make history again Pompeii in
this ancient Roman city a disaster was
frozen in time forever in 79 AD a
volcano buried Pompeii under a thick
carpet of volcanic ash 2,000 of the
20,000 people living there passed away
during this tragic event most of them
had plenty of time to escape but others
stayed behind
they stood there like statues before the
city was abandoned for hundreds of years
then in 1748 explorers discovered the
ancient city of pompeii but what
surprised them the most was that
underneath the dust everything was
mostly intact it was like nothing had
changed since that final day what was a
tragedy became a treasure to historians
visiting Pompeii was like traveling in
the past and learning more about the
lifestyle of those who lived there
almost 2,000 years ago the most
distinguished citizens lived in that
town archaeologists even found jars of
preserved fruits and loaves of bread but
these findings also influenced the
culture of the 18th century the
wealthiest families in Europe had
reproductions of objects from the ruins
and Pompeii inspired architectural
trends from the era and there are still
so many things to discover in Pompeii
nowadays but we can't help but wonder
what would happen if a volcano erupted
in this moment what would your dust
statue look like if people found you
into
thousand years penicillin the discovery
of penicillin marks a turning point in
human history before that day if you
were sick one of the best things to do
was to say your prayers
but when Alexander Fleming found out
what would become one of the very first
antibiotics thousands of lives changed
and that discovery would not have been
possible if the bacteriologist didn't do
something we all do he didn't clean his
lab among the mess he found out that
bacterias next to the penicillin mold
didn't grow as they normally do this
unusual substance got rid of these
harmful microorganisms after a few more
weeks of research with he concluded that
it could be used as a way to treat
dangerous infections Fleming wrote in a
letter in 1928 that he didn't plan to
revolutionize all medicine that morning
but that's exactly what he did
he then started working with professor
Howard Florey the one that made
everything possible 14 years later and
Miller was the first civilian patient
whose life was saved by the antibiotic
and she was certainly not the last one
this is how Fleming and his team won a
Nobel Prize in 1945 we can't believe
that so many lives were saved because
his lab bench was messy what if you
could win a Nobel Prize from what you
would find in your room if you didn't
clean it laughs the first human no the
first man wasn't named Adam and the
first woman wasn't e the oldest known
species in the human family tree was the
Sahel anthropocentrism the specimen in
2001 no one could pretend that we were
not related to monkeys if you take a
look at this reconstitution you'll see
what we are talking about the first
human lived between 7 & 6 million years
ago in West Central Africa it had a
combination of ape-like and human-like
features it had a small brain very
prominent brow ridges and a lot of hair
but just like us they also had small
canine teeth a short middle part of the
face and a spinal cord that let them
walk upright this discovery helped us
understand more things about our early
ancestors other discoveries like the
Homo erectus and Homo neanderthalensis
also helped us understand what makes us
Homo sapiens today
this species of human has been on earth
for 200,000 years however don't think
humans descend from monkeys
we are both primates but humans and
chimpanzees both evolved differently
from a common ancestor that lived 8
million years ago the dinosaurs we are
so fascinated by these creatures from
the past so imagine what British
scientist Richard Owen felt like when he
was the first to discover a dinosaur in
1842 he described them as immense
animals that were the most perfect
modifications of the reptilian type
scientists already knew that gigantic
sea reptiles existed but Owen was the
first to write about reptiles that lived
on earth the first one to be found was a
predatory lizard called the Megalosaurus
he first thought that it measured 30
feet long but later found out that it
was 70 feet long it's just as tall as
the White House many other immense
reptiles were found in the following
years and Owen proposed that they were
all related he named them dinosaurs
which means terrible lizard in Greek
this discovery helped us understand how
life started on earth from almost 250
million years ago until their extinction
66 million years ago and there are still
so many things to learn about them did
you know the dinosaurs don't look like
what you usually see in pictures they
actually had feathers but unfortunately
most of them couldn't fly and did you
know that you can still see dinosaurs
today modern birds are descendants of a
group of two-legged dinosaurs so
whenever you eat chicken you're actually
eating what used to be a giant terrible
lizard Stonehenge for centuries
historians and archaeologists tried to
discover Stonehenge's mysteries the most
iconic prehistoric ruin in England why
did people take thousands of years to
place 100 massive stones in a circular
layout 5,000 years ago many people
believe that it was used as a burial
site but it could be much more than that
a ceremonial site a place of healing a
religious pilgrimage destination a
memorial to connect with ancestors or
the final resting place for someone who
was really important it could also be an
astronomical calendar because the stones
correspond to different astrological
phenomena all these theories gave
historians the chance to learn
more about the culture of those who
lived thousands of years ago historians
also wanted to know how people even
build Stonehenge without modern
technology the wheel wasn't even
invented yet the stones weighed up to 40
tons and some of them were transported
over 200 miles historians believe that
builders used sleds and ropes to carry
the stones it is also possible that tree
trunks were used as rollers or that they
used large boats some scientists even
suggested that glaciers were responsible
for this
even though historians scientists and
archeologists didn't find an answer they
learned so many things by asking all
these questions electricity could you
imagine a life without electricity you
couldn't be watching this video you
wouldn't be able to use a computer or a
cell phone and you would have to use
candles to light your house electricity
always existed but it is when someone
found a way to use it to our advantage
that our lives changed forever the
electrical charge was first discovered
in ancient Greece 2600 years ago in fact
researchers believe that the battery
could have been invented 2,000 years ago
they found an urn that contained a
copper pipe an iron rod and the residue
of an acidic liquid when a team of
scientists tried to do the same
experiment they produced 4.5 volts
unfortunately this invention was
forgotten for thousands of years it was
not until the 18th century that Benjamin
Franklin started experimenting with a
kite a key and a storm he wanted to
prove that lightning was electricity
however it was nothing but a dangerous
experiment at the time we had to wait
for Alessandro Volta to discover a
steady flow of electrical charge this is
how he invented the battery a reliable
source of electricity that inspired many
scientists and researchers more people
work to explain our knowledge of
electricity so we could learn how to
control this force of nature if only we
started using electricity in our daily
lives since ancient times imagine how it
would have changed history as we know it
the earth people obviously notice that
they were walking on earth since the
beginning of history but there were so
many things that they didn't know about
you might think that Christopher
Columbus was the first Explorer who
wanted to prove that the earth was round
when everyone thought it was flat but
that's not true
ancient Greeks
actually knew about it thousands of
years ago Aristotle was the first to
prove that the earth was round by
looking at the Stars there were
different sets of stars in the sky
depending on where you were this is how
he understood that people all around the
world were not looking at the same night
sky
Eratosthenes went even further and
estimated the Earth's circumference and
that's not the only crazy thing that
Greeks found out about 2,000 years ago
Copernicus was not the first to prove
that the earth was not the center of the
universe ancient Greeks knew about
planets like Mercury Venus Mars Jupiter
and Saturn but most of them thought the
earth was the center of the universe
only one of them had a better idea
Aristarchus of Samos presented the first
known model that placed the Sun at the
center of the known universe in the 3rd
century this is how science changed the
way we see the whole universe DNA this
discovery helped us understand the
history of ourselves and what makes us
who we are
DNA was first discovered in 1869 but it
was not until almost a hundred years
later that people understood its use in
the 20th century many scientists tried
to study DNA James D Watson and Francis
H C Crick were the first to describe the
molecule containing human genes the
double helix structure of DNA at that
time they thought that they had found
the secret of life and they weren't so
far from that it was a turning point in
understanding life and biology hasn't
been the same since understanding DNA
was like discovering the code that is
used to make a computer work and once
the code was cracked in the 1960s
scientists have been working on becoming
the programmers of our bodies it helped
us understand where we came from it gave
us the chance to challenge racial
prejudices it reunited families it
changed the way we eat we have learned
to swap chunks of DNA between species to
give them special characteristics we can
now understand predict and cure
inherited diseases it helped us solve
crimes and identify the guilty nowadays
DNA is still one of the things that
scientists are the most interested in
and once we have the chance to
understand who we are we'll be able to
become anything we want to be and that's
it for 10 amazing discoveries that
rewrote history
which one do you think had the greatest
influence on our lives don't be shy to
tell us in the comments down below and
for more videos like this don't forget
to subscribe to the things and watch 10
amazing pictures they won't show you in
history books thanks for watching we'll
see you next time bye bye
[Music]